hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from Huawei Netherlands it was
played in 2003 between unit polgár and
anatoly karpov
but before we check out the game i would
like to just thank everyone for taking
the time to vote for our next big saga
it's only been one day
but already 30,000 of you have voted
these are the results so far we have
unit poker saga 17% Paul Morphy saga 35%
alien saga 12% Petros and saga 7% and
anatoly karpov saga 28% so basically
it's it's between Paul Morphy and
Anatoly Karpov
but like I said only thirty thousand
votes so far the poll is still young and
if you want to contribute to our next
big saga cast your vote the first link
in the description below will take you
to our community tab where you can vote
on the next big saga so you know and
also maybe maybe drop a comment the who
wins I mean if if a certain saga wins
the poll it doesn't mean that we are
going to do that saga but it will
greatly influence my decision of course
so that being said let's check out this
very nice game
like I said 2003 who Gawain Netherlands
and this is the seventh edition of the
tournament and basically they were
organizing it they had the world
champion well former world champion
Anatoly Karpov here they had the world
junior champion this year was 11 iron
and they had the Dutch champion even
Sokolov and the top-rated wooden player
Judit Polgar so it's a four player
tournament everyone faces each other
twice and in the end who emerges
victorious so this is the this is a game
from round 1 it's really really well
interesting so I do hope you enjoy it
without further ado let's check it out
the unit opens the with efore as usually
does with E 5 by Karpov from Knight to
f3 Knight to f6 corporal goes for the
Petrov defense and now just Knight
captures on e5 going for the main line
with d69 back to f3 and now Knight
captures on e4
so d4 by unit this is the classical
attack against the petrov d5 and the
bush of the d3 this is a still all
played today so nothing nothing out of
the ordinary ordinary Bishop to e7 we
have castles by unit and Knight to c6
we have c4 these this is still all
standard stuff Knights the before going
after the disappear and now Bishop to e2
is still the most popular move even in
2019 we have castles by Karpov ending
out a three pushing the knight back we
have Knight to c6 and now see chapters
on d5 inviting the Queen so you can
develop the knight with tempo so the
Queen captures on d5 by Karpov with
Knight to c3 and now a trade on c3
Knight captures B captures and here now
the main move today is Bishop to f5 and
for good reason it guards the b1 square
it gets the piece into the game prevents
rugby one but in 2003 carpet went for
Queen to d6 got the Queen out of the way
he plans on developing the Bishop to e6
but maybe it's not the most precise move
order as Bishop to f5 would have been
better as well one of the reasons why
it's the main move today in the position
and you that goes look the b1
immediately now you cannot develop the
bishop because you lose the b7 pawn so
here Karpov is forced to play b6 if he
wants to develop the light-square bishop
we have rook to e1 by unit and now
Bishop to e6 developing the bishop this
way with Bishop back to d3 now wasting a
move
well not wasting move sort of losing a
temple but you have to Karpov also lost
the tempo you're going tonight to be
four back to c6 so it's not really a
problem getting the bishop to are much
more useful diagonal and here carpel
goes the rook 88 so here so there it's a
very interesting position and the
position really offers a lot here you
did played rook the b5 it's a very very
nice rook lift you can bring the rook
all the way into the attack if necessary
or you can just go rogue b5 rook to e5
to double rooks as you already have a
look on a 1 now there is the possibility
of going look captures on e6 right away
but it's such a well to play this
against Anatoly Karpov it's just I don't
think you know anyone would dare play
such a move of course you cannot capture
with the Queen due to d5 winning yet
another piece winning the knight here
because if you capture Jo special
characters on h7 and then you
who's the queen however after rook
captures you can play F captures and now
the point is that Queen to c2 is just
such a strong move but it's it's very
hard to calculate all of the ins and
outs for example if you go h6 then you
really weaken the lights whereas if h6
then just then you can go Queen to e -
Quinta e4 and the black will constantly
have problems along the light squares
even if you go g6 white can even just
pick it up just the bishop characters in
g6 so there are a lot a lot of
possibilities here there's a there's
really really a lot but like I said
playing such a move just you know
sacrificing rook on e6 and then going
Queen to c2 against anatoly karpov I I
don't think so so here you did goes for
the safer approach rook to b5 just a
very nice rook lift preparing to bring
this rook into the game as well and now
Knight to a5 by Karpov probably
preparing to kick the rook away and
maybe with c6 and also you you do get
control of the b3 squared if the rook
ever moves from the B file also you get
control of the C 4 square so there are
some uses to the knight being on a5 for
the moment but here usually just goes
rook to e5 and Karpov pushes it back
nice the c6 and here again if it was if
it was possible to sacrifice any six
then is it even possible now it is but
still it's it's a bit of a different
position so if rook captures now a queen
capture still doesn't work now due to
the obvious reasons of the India rugby
here
so after F captures on e6 Queen to c2 is
again very strong and here okay yeah we
already said h6 creates a lot of light
square weaknesses you could just you
know get your Queen Queen into the
attack if g 6g 6 is well you just pick
it up it's not a problem H captures
Queen captures with check King here you
give a check King goes to Jade and now
look the e4 will finish the game very
nicely with with this rook lift so here
after Queen to c2 it obviously in g6 and
h6 doesn't really work for black but
what if Luke captures on f3 and here is
where the line gets really interesting
and probably one of the reasons why you
did did not go for root characters
he says it because it's just becomes
very complicated Bishop captures on h7
checking a fate now you have to win back
the exchange into now after Bishop to f6
the material is well white is up upon
but still it's a it's a really crazy
position and India and white will our
white will be better but it requires a
lot of calculation still I do have to
mention you're playing Anatoly Karpov
and you don't want to burn all of your
bridges you know before before the end
of the game but here okay after Bishop
to g6 you do get you do get a lot of
play with white if black wants to save
the rook let's say Rudy now you make
room for the Queen and you will
constantly have issues here with with
black so really really an interesting
variation but you did retreats with the
rook we have looked back to e to look to
III probably possible but then again you
still haven't developed your dark square
Bishop your Knight is blocking you from
you know just roaming the third-ranked
so for the moment rook to e2 we'll see
what happens next we have Bishop to d7
by Karpov now just preparing Bishop to
f6 to trade some rooks along the e-file
and here usually goes d5 and doesn't
allow the knight to go anywhere in the
center forces the knight back to the to
the edge of the board we have Knight
back to a5 and now if unit was a was a
positional player we would see c4 Bishop
to f6 and then the game continues but
unit is an attacker she goes Knight to
e5 just you know it brings a piece
closer to the enemy King if you will and
here what do you play okay Karpov
continues Bishop to f6 he wants to trade
pieces again f4 is a possibility but
after f4 black will of course not trade
and I allow you this beautiful Center so
you did to decides for Bishop to f4
instead Corp of trades will Bishop
captures with Bishop captures on e5 now
yudishtir
wins the bishop repair and the carp of
grabs a pawn with Queen captures on a3
and here what do you do well you brought
another piece into the game not
interested in ideas like captures on c7
which would just allow carp of the trade
pieces rook to e3
now it's it now this is a very nice rock
lift again because this rock came all
the way from b1 it went b5 - d5 - e -
and only now to e3
and from e3 now the rope can roam the
e-file and create some threats against
the black king and here karpova karpova
spidey-sense should have been tingling
here he has to play g6 prevent some you
know prevent prevented again Bishop here
from hell we could call him that but
Karpov played Queen to c5 and Queen to
c5 is just too slow over move here so
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure out why Queen to c5 doesn't work
and check if your spidey sense is
tingling so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
such such a beautiful - bishop sacrifice
and if you're if you're familiar with it
it's basically a manual Lasker's a
patent sacrifice you sacrifice the
bishop deliver a check and then you
sacrifice the other bishop because the
rook is ready to enter the attack so
here you displayed bishop character sin
h7 width check it doesn't matter if you
decline the sacrifice Queen to h5 is a
deadly either way so here Karpov
captured it and we have Queen to h5 with
check and after this Queen to h5 check
Anatoly Karpov resigned the game and it
was a remarkable victory for you that in
round one of the who win a tournament in
Netherlands as well you again I have to
repeat you're playing Anatoly Karpov
here you don't just beat him in 2026
moves especially with a double Bishop
sacrifice here he resigns because after
the King moves which is the only move
now you continue with Bishop captures
and g7 this is what what's meant with a
double Bishop sacrifice and now if King
captures it's well it's pretty straight
forward rubgy three check King moves and
now Queen to g5 is mate
the king has nowhere to go the work
controls the entire efile and even if
you don't capture the bishop well the
Queen h8 is a threat so you have to do
something you can just do nothing if you
try something like f6 to create to
create some room for your for King maybe
on f7 if Queen to h8 it doesn't really
matter just Bishop captures and f6 is
sufficient because now well if you
capture on e3 Queen g6 is mate
there's also this mate and if you don't
if you captured the bishop then again
it's just rook the g3 check King to f8
we have Queen the8 check the rook still
covers the entire eval King f7 and now
rook to g7 will be made so after Queen
to h5 carpel resigned and a wonderful
victory for you this polgár in round one
of the the who were in tournament and
that we also prepared the final
standings of this tournament so here
they are
as you can see you did took first place
with four four out of six points Levin
took second place with three out of six
tying with even Sokolov and anatoly
karpov finished last with two out of six
points not not the greatest tournament
for him but in those days he didn't play
all that much classical chassis more
played more of a rapid chess if you will
and yeah you did the only game you did
last year it was the even Sokolov soccer
also played a brilliant game sacrificing
pieces always a very nice game but yeah
just as the way we did have a in in the
poll
you know if any of you were interested
in you polgár saga so for the moment
only 17% for you did poker but just if
you wanted to check out some or some of
our games this is one such game so I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Ignacio all Fryeburg Gregoire
cherylin and [ __ ] Rudin Jean each for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check too in my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continue to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and well we do have the data
still coming up soon in India so we're
gonna cover that as well and I'm gonna
leave the the poll to be you know
gaining votes for for some maybe a week
and then we're gonna decide on the next
big saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day